President Trump may be abandoned Syria
to the Turks but not without a few
parting Twitter shots courts debate
whether to force the release of
president from tax returns and Elizabeth
Warren takes command of the 2020
democratic race this is the Ben Shapiro
show sponsored by expressvpn protect
your online privacy today at expressvpn
calm / Ben
oh man there's a lot to get to today so
let's just jump right in first this
situation in northern Syria is at the
very least deeply puzzling it is morally
troubling it's pretty awful all the way
through here at CNN reporting in a
remarkable announcement late on Sunday
night the White House said that the
United States forces in northern Syria
would move aside in advance of a plan to
Turkish military offensive the move
marks a major shift in u.s. foreign
policy effectively gives Turkey the
green light to attack US backed Kurdish
forces which would make just the latest
time that we have betrayed at the Kurds
obviously the United States has
repeatedly told the Kurds that they were
our allies and that we were working with
them only to put them in a situation
where they were basically screwed that
happened during the Gulf War in 1991
when George HW Bush called for the Iraqi
military and Iraqi people to throw out
Saddam Hussein and the Iraqi Kurds in
northern Iraq then actually stood up and
tried to do that at which point Saddam
Hussein basically gassed them and mowed
them down and the United States did
nearly nothing about any of that during
the late 1990s during the Clinton
administration the Clinton
administration basically armed the Turks
that they could go ahead and kill a
bunch of the Kurds on the Turkish border
during the Iraq war in 2003 there were
moves to help the Kurds and then the
Kurds were basically left to their own
devices the Kurds also were targeted by
Isis so this is just the latest
iteration of a common pattern which is
that we all sound off when it's time to
help the Kurds and then the minute that
it becomes an odd time to help the Kurds
everybody runs screaming for the exits
and that's just horrible every way you
slice it there is no rationale not only
for not actually allowing the Kurds to
defend themselves here and providing
them the resources to do so considering
they have been our most consistent ally
in that region of the world fighting
against Isis fighting against Saddam
Hussein fighting against the Iranian
Shia militias not only that but helping
out the Turks is a horrible idea because
the Turkish government right now is run
by Recep Tayyip Erdogan who happens to
be a dictator and an incredibly
repressive dictator at that who has
jailed hundreds of thousands of
political opponents who has made clear
his desire to act brutally and violently
toward the Kurds but President Trump
been taking him by air too long before
he's had these sort of warm relations
with with the air Diwan in terms of
phone calls at the very least according
to CNN following a phone call between a
u.s. president Donald Trump and Turkish
president received a perdu on the White
House said that Turkey would soon begin
a military offensive and US forces would
not be involved in the operation turkey
will soon be moving forward with its
long planned operation into northern
Syria a statement said the US Armed
Forces will not support or be involved
in the operation and US forces having
defeated the ISIS territorial Caliphate
will no longer be in the immediate area
now this is exactly the sort of foreign
policy that there's some on the right
who definitely want to see pursuit and
there are some people who are on the
right who tend to be in the more sort of
Pat Buchanan isolationist camp who
basically suggest the US has no business
in that part of the world well that's
all fun and games until it turns out
that you're allowing the Turks and the
Turkish government to slaughter the
Kurds who have allied with the United
States to take on a common foe in Isis
the White House added that Turkey would
now be responsible for all captured Isis
fighters are currently being held by US
backed Kurdish forces in northern Syria
in other words they're fine with the
Turks going in presumably wiping out the
Kurds or at least attacking at the Kurds
and then taking control of Isis
prisoners but as we've been saying for
years on this program there are very few
forces in the region that actually had
an interest in seeing Isis completely
wiped out the Turks wanted Isis there so
that they could use it as an excuse to
cross over into Syria the Syrian
government wanted Isis there so they
could use it as an excuse as to why they
should remain in power the Iranians
wanted Isis there for the same reason as
the Syrians only the Kurds really and
freedom and and freedom fighting Syrians
or anti Isis and yet now we I guess are
out handing leadership role over to air
Dewan as though he's a good faith actor
in all of this and is not simply seeking
to wipe out the Kurds and create a
quote-unquote buffer zone for Turkey the
White House added at that as of last
month the u.s. 1000 US troops were
operating in north eastern Syria so
there's just the small trigger force and
that was preventing all of this from
happening presumably that is no longer
going to be the case
sundae's statement did not specify if
this constituted a full withdrawal of
personnel from the country air21
confirmed on Monday according to CNN the
US troops had begun withdrawing from
northeastern Syria he announced on
Saturday that Turkey had quote completed
our preparations in action
and was ready to launch a ground and air
operation east of the Euphrates River
with the goal of establishing
quote-unquote peace by clearing the
region of terrorists Turkey's operation
is aimed at clearing the us-backed
Kurdish militia the people's protection
units away from Turkey's border because
presumably an attempted an attempt to
broaden Kurdistan would include some
sort of incursions into Turkish
territory there have been long-standing
territorial and border disputes between
the Kurds and the Turks Ankara which is
the capital of Turkey
regards the YPG as a terrorist group
affiliated with the Kurdistan Workers
Party which has fought the Turkish state
for more than three decades but the us
back to the YPG and credits the Kurds
for helping to defeat Isis in Syria so
this one is thanks for all the help of
Isis guys also we're gonna let the cards
come in and wipe you out now Turkey has
been working with us to establish safe
zones
that run along the turkey-syria border
but Anadolu reports that while turkey
welcomes the joint patrols it has also
said the u.s. is not doing enough to set
up the safe zone properly presumably
these safe zones will be for Syrian
refugees who have been swapping Turkey
more than a million Syrian refugees
during the Sierra Leone a Syrian civil
war have moved into Turkey air Dewan
expressed frustration with president
Trump and the US military's failure to
implement an agreement between the two
nations according to a readout of
alcohol released by the Turkish
presidency and the two leaders agreed to
meet in Washington next month at Trump's
invitation now you remember the last
time air toulon showed up his thugs
ended up beating up a bunch of
anti-regime protestors in Washington DC
in a created natural international
incident the buffer zone the u.s. calls
that a security mechanism would be part
of a bid to prevent a military incursion
into the area that would target Syrian
Kurdish groups so presumably the United
States is saying okay we'll set up these
safe zones but we don't have enough
troops to prevent the Turks from
actually going in and doing what it is
they see fit to do according to CNN
Trump's decision to allow air to want to
move forward with the operation and to
move US forces out of the area goes
against US officials their efforts to
dissuade turkey from carrying out a
military intervention a pentagon
spokesman named Sean Robertson said
quote any uncoordinated military
operation by turkey would be of grave
concern who would undermine our shared
interest of a secure Northeast Syria and
the enduring defeat of Isis on Monday a
pentagon spokesperson said the
Department of Defense actually did not
even endorse at the planned operation so
Trump is over
rolling his own Defense Department here
the Department of Defense made clear to
Turkey as did the president we do not
endorse a Turkish operation in northern
Syria it's apparently Trump had said he
doesn't want it but what's actually
gonna stop the Turks really does anybody
actually think that the United States is
gonna do anything to prevent all of us
on Saturday Secretary of State by Pompeo
told reporters quote we've made clear
this conflict should not be militarized
but a US official familiar with
operations in Syria told CNN it is
quote-unquote very likely that turkey
will try something soon they said that
Ankara the the again capital of Turkey
will start with limited incursion to
establish Turkish patrol bases on the
Syrian side of the border and then
eventually when the world's attention
turns away from this issue then they
will launch into trying to clean up
meaning clean out and kill members of
the PKK in a second we'll get to the
fact that this is actually created some
blowback on the right side of the as
well it should because frankly it's
terrible terrible horrible not moral
policy I'll get to that in just a second
first let's talk about neighborhood
safety so I am deeply invested in safely
safety now when I say I'm deeply
invested I mean like we spend many many
many dollars here at my company and at
my home on my personal safety the safety
of my family unfortunately receive a lot
of threats we have stalkers all sorts of
wonderful people looking out for us and
that is why we rely on ring to keep our
neighborhood safe rings mission is to
make your neighborhood safe as well you
might already know about their smart
video doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor you will
get an alert you'll be able to see here
speak to them all from your phone and
does make me feel a lot safer makes my
wife feel a lot safer as well both of us
are very safety conscious if we're both
out of the house we want to know who's
at the front gate when my kids are home
with the nanny as a subscriber you have
a special offer on a ring welcome can
available right this moment at ring.com
slash bet and the kit includes a ring
video doorbell - and a chime Pro which
is just what you need to start building
a ring of security around your home
today go to ring.com slash Ben that is
ring.com
slash Ben additional terms may apply go
check it out right now ring.com slash
mad ok so Senator Lindsey Graham has
tweeted the decision to abandon our
Kurdish allies and turn Syria over to
Russia Iran and Turkey will put every
radical Islamist on steroids it's a shot
in the arm to the bad guys devastating
for the
guys Brett McGurk is the former US envoy
to the anti-isis coalition he ripped
into Trump he said he was quote not a
commander-in-chief and quote makes
impulsive decisions with no knowledge or
deliberation he says he blusters and
leaves our allies exposed when
adversaries call his bluff or he
confronts a hard phonecall nikki Haley
the former US ambassador to view and
under Trump reiterated on target on
Twitter that Kurdish fighters were quote
instrumental in our successful fight
against Isis in Syria and added that the
u.s. must always have the back of our
allies if we expect them to have our
back and obviously the the Kurds are not
exactly sanguine about all of this they
are very upset because they are seeing
the possibility of actual violence done
to them by the Turks with the United
States backing off of all of this the
Kurds of course are telling the Pentagon
that this is insanity that this is just
that there's no rationale for it because
frankly there is no rationale for it
other than the general isolationist
rationale of the United States should
not be involved anywhere around the
world even to help people who helped to
us wipe out people who are trying to
murder Americans and Westerners around
the world well this is prompted Mitch
McConnell to sound off again you know
things are bad when the Republican Party
starts to tell President Trump that he
needs to cut this nonsense out Mitch
McConnell sounded off he released a
statement he said in January a
supermajority of the US Senate voted for
an amendment that expressed bipartisan
concern about the continuing threat
posed by Isis and al Qaeda in Syria
appreciation of the long term American
security interest in Syria and the
region and support for a continued
military presence in northeastern Syria
the conditions that produce this
bipartisan vote still exist today while
the physical Caliphate has been removed
Isis and al Qaeda remain dangerous
forces in Syria and the ongoing Syrian
civil war poses significant security and
humanitarian risks a precipitous
withdrawal of US forces from Syria would
only benefit Russia Iran and the Assad
regime now I will note that all the
members of the media for ripping on
Trump over this you know that and they
seemed a lot more sanguine when Barack
Obama was creating fake red lines about
gassing Syrians and then he proceeded to
pull out from Syria and hand the whole
thing over to the Russians with that
said is it any better if Trump is doing
something similar of course not it would
increase the risk that Isis and other
terrorist groups regrew
according to McConnell I urged the
President to exercise American
leadership to keep together our
multinational coalition to defeat Isis
and prevent significant conflict between
our NATO ally Turkey and our local
Syrian counterterrorism partners major
new conflicts between Turkey and our
partners in Syria would seriously risk
damaging Turkey's ties to the US and
causing greater isolation for Turkey on
the world stage turkey is an Islamist
force they have been unfortunately for
the last 15 to 20 years under Diwan
aired Ilan turned what was a secular
state into an Islamist State or at least
a state moving in Islamist direction
they have backed Hamas they have backed
terrorist groups they have attempted to
wipe out allies of the United States the
fact that President Trump is is
apparently caving before air Dewan is
frankly pathetic McConnell says as we
learned the hard way during the Obama
administration American interests are
best served by American leadership not
by with would not by retreat or
withdrawal apparently the concerns about
an Isis comeback are quite serious
especially because one of the things
that would happen if the Kurds were to
withdrawals who exactly is gonna be
running the prisons that are holding
tens of thousands of Isis fighters the
Turks how's that gonna go well the
answer is it probably will not Mitt
Romney has sounded off on this as well
he said quote the president's decision
to abandon our Kurd allies in the face
of an assault by Turkey is a betrayal it
says that America is an unreliable ally
it facilitates Isis resurgence it pre
Sage's another humanitarian disaster so
when you got McConnell and Romney on the
same page it is fair to say that there
is pretty solid opposition to president
Trump's move right here at the State
Department a senior official authorized
to brief reporters on the condition of
anonymity denied suggestions that Trump
had endorsed a Turkish incursion he said
we do not support this operation in any
way shape or form but the timing of the
Turks basically announcing an incursion
and the timing of President Trump
announcing we're gonna pull out it's
obviously not a giant coincidence
there's been a lot of talk about
President Trump ramping a parade with
Turkey and friendliness between the
United States and Turkey according to a
State Department official the original
call between Trump and air Dewan
originated as a conversation about the
air defense issue and economic
cooperation and then air Dewan raised
going into northeastern Syria claiming
that the safe zone
mechanism that was set up and was being
executed was not meeting his needs and
that he wanted to do a unilateral
operation but apparently according to
the State Department official
there was no specific indication that he
would push the button we still don't
know in the end what he is going to do
okay but if you don't know what he's
going to do and then you signal that
we're going to pull out obviously that
signal is going to be taken as a sign of
weakness by air Dewan so that's
obviously some bad bad policy now
president Trump seems to be backing off
of the policy so this is the thing that
I don't really understand about the
perspective on president Trump that
suggests that criticizing President
Trump weakens President Trump I don't
think that that is correct if you are
criticizing him not to undermine his
presidency but to point out when he is
making a mistake because President Trump
does have the capacity to shift policy
we have seen him do it before when he
steps over a line if the right is
willing to call him out then he was
stuck back over the line on the right
side of the line we'll get to that in
one second president Trump seeming to
walk all of this back get into that in
just one second first they tell you
something I just took a very very long
flight to Israel okay so I am over here
right now and then my kids decided you
know it'd be awesome is to not sleep
ever so I've had like three hours of
sleep
in the last 40 which is one of the
reasons why I really appreciate black
rifle coffee there's nothing quite like
black rifle coffee when it comes to
giving you a kick directly in the pants
with tons of different roasts
to choose from black rifle ships the
best roasts to order coffee directly to
your door a portion of all black rifles
profits go to supporting veteran law
enforcement fire and first responder
causes when you drink black rifle coffee
you're supporting a company that serves
coffee and culture to people who truly
love the country I know the dudes who
run black rifle coffee by the way
awesome dudes mean manly men military
dudes these are people who not only can
trust to make great coffee but frankly
you trusted them to help protect the
country
they are awesome awesome fellows if
you've been on the fence about joining
black rifle coffee there's no better
time than right now help them reach
their goal of hitting a hundred thousand
club members by the end of this month
get access to discounts and offers not
available to other customers visit black
rifle coffee calm slash Ben get 20% off
your first purchase that is black rifle
coffee calm slash Ben for 20% off that
first purchase again black rifle coffee
calm slash Ben hey so many people on the
right are very upset about this
obviously you are starting to see some
on the right defend President Trump
president Trump then sent out a bizarre
series of tweets walking this thing back
and again this is just proof positive
then when Trump does something wrong and
you call him out on it he is capable of
hearing it and changing in the most
bizarre possible way apparently so
President Trump tweeted this one out and
this is this is a classic Trump wait I
mean this is this is the full Trump man
here he is as I have stated strongly
before and just to reiterate if Turkey
does anything that I in my great and
unmatched wisdom considered to be
off-limits I will totally destroy Anna
blip litter eight the economy of Turkey
I've done before exclamation point
they must with Europe and others watch
over the captured Isis fighters and
Families the US has done far more than
anyone could have ever expected
including the capture of one hundred
percent of the Isis Caliphate it is time
now for others in the region some of
great wealth to protect their own
territory the USA is great all capital
letters hmm okay
well that last part right there about
how he expects Turkey to maintain the
Isis fighters in custody he's not saying
a lot about the protection of the Kurds
who helped us defeat Isis right there is
he
president Trump then said this is all
part of America first to foreign
policies as we will fight where it is to
our benefit and only fight to win okay
but there's also a point of American
foreign policy and that's called
deterrence and one of the reasons that
we keep for example a trigger a trigger
force in South Korea is to deter the
North Koreans from invading South Korea
why well some people say well we should
get out there what what interests do we
have in Korea we have an interest in
internet being a hot war between North
Korea and South Korea that draws in
China and then forces the intervention
of other powers including the United
States see sometimes in ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of brutality
on the other end and pulling out and
signaling to the Turks that you're going
to do so is obviously not good policy
you do have to love the snidely whiplash
sort of language right there from
President Trump and his great and
unmatched wisdom
it's like Jafar in Aladdin his great and
unmatched wisdom if you will not bow
before a sultan you will cower before a
source what is
my great and unmatched wisdom I'll
totally destroy and obliterate the
economy of Turkey I've done it before I
mean it is true that he has obviously
had significant impact on the economy of
ron's and presumably his threatening
sanctions on Turkey five minutes after
telling Turkey that he would like for
them to enter that buffer zone and then
it will pull out or something like that
it's all confused it is all confusing
consistency in foreign policy actually
matters now look when it comes to
president Trump and his sort of fly by
the seat of his pants policy I've
generally not been supremely critical
the reason being I don't think that you
don't necessarily have to have a plan I
think that the constitutional checks and
boundaries prevent an impulsive
president from doing too much damage
that is not nearly as true when it comes
to foreign policy the reason it's not as
true when it comes to foreign policy is
because an impulse can sometimes create
a similarly countervailing impulse on
the other side a weakness can sometimes
be taken as a measure that somebody
should do something to you I take it as
an example the first Gulf War there were
high ranking at negotiating officials
inside the HW Bush administration who
allegedly signal to the Saddam Hussein
regime that if Hussein would walk into
Kuwait the United States would basically
do nothing at which point Hussein said
okay fine so I'll walk into Kuwait and
then the United States was at war and
I'm glad that President Trump walked it
back within 24 hours and this is why
people should criticize him when he
deserves the critique there's the again
this bizarre belief that you can never
criticize President Trump that he can't
take it
the man was fairly tough you may have
noticed he's taken an awful amount of
abuse and crap over the last several
years I think he can handle some people
saying that his Turkish policy is a bad
idea especially when he has kowtow to
one of the worst dictators on the planet
I mean everyone really is terrible he
really has taken Turkey from was a
burgeoning Western country back into an
Islamist country run by a regime that
does not care about human rights or
freedom and threatens its neighbors it's
it's really bad it's really bad so I'm
glad that president from seems to be
walking this thing back at least but
that sort of temporary boo-boo has
raised hackles everywhere and I will
point out that when it comes to people
on the Left who are suddenly finding
their spine when it comes to criticizing
American foreign policy in Syria welcome
to the club and it's it's wonderful
see you here I'm so glad that you could
finally make it after years of you
pretending that Barack Obama's foreign
policy in Syria was a symptom of great
genius that his fly by the seat of his
pants foreign policy handing over power
in Syria to Vladimir Putin and the
Iranians that that was actually a
measure of his broad heartedness and
genius glad does welcome you to the club
where it turns out that a predictable
American foreign policy is useful in
this arena of the world I welcome people
like Thomas Friedman Paul Paul Krugman
Paul Krugman tweeted out there are only
a few reasons why Trump would do this
one would be he's trying to kowtow to
Russia one is that he's impulsive okay
yeah it's funny how Paul Krugman didn't
have all that much to say when Barack
Obama was drawing fake red lines about
the use of chemical weapons against
Syrian citizens and then immediately
went silent when that red line
disappeared and Brocklin was like hey
what if we just give this thing over to
my my good friend Vlad give him some
flexibility and now he'll help me on
Syria and shortly thereafter the rise of
Isis began in that's not a defense of
trumpian policy it is to point out the
hypocrisy of the left that apparently
does not care about this stuff unless
there's an R next to the name of the
person who is running the executive
branch of the United States government
okay meanwhile the impeachment stuff
continues to burgeon the Democrats have
a new angle because every 30 seconds or
so they have to come up with a new angle
because it seems like the angles they've
taken so far are insufficient so now
they're going after president Trump's
taxes we'll get to that in just one
second first let me tell you something
last night as I've been saying didn't
sleep great okay I am NOT in my bed at
home and it's not just about being at
home it's also about the fact that when
I am at home I have one of the world's
great mattresses I have a helix
sleep mattress helix sleep has a quiz it
takes two minutes to complete it matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you no matter
how you sleep side back hot sleep or
whatever helix can make what your body
needs just go to helix sleep calm /ban
take their two-minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life again when I'm on the road I
can't wait to get back on that helix
sleep mattress my bed last night did not
match up for couples helix can even
split that mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side I've got
a 10 year warranty you get to try it out
for a hundred nights at risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you are going to love
it helix is offering up to
and $25 off all mattress orders for our
listeners gap to 125 bucks off at helix
sleep comm slash been at helix sleep
comm slash been from to 125 bucks off
your mattress order that's helix sleep
comm slash man okay meanwhile in other
news president Trump's taxes are
apparently now the subject of a massive
legal dispute according to the New York
Times yesterday a federal judge on
Monday rejected president Trump's
efforts to shield his tax returns from
Manhattan's state prosecutors calling
the president's argument that he was
immune from criminal investigation quote
repugnant to the nation's governmental
structure and constitutional values well
I mean I thought that we had already
litigated whether the president is
immune from criminal proceedings
President Clinton was brought up well he
wasn't brought up criminal he's brought
civilly I suppose he's not immune the
civil suit it is a matter of controversy
over whether the president is able to be
prosecuted in state or federal court
while he's the president there was that
famous DOJ Office of Legal Counsel
opinion that sort of suggested that you
can't prosecute the president federally
while he is sitting and it would be kind
of bizarre if state governments could
prosecute the President of the United
States because then presumably they
could they'd always have this sort of
check on the presidential power but if
the president were to hit somebody with
his car could he be prosecuted in the
state of New York if he actually shot
somebody on Fifth Avenue
could he be prosecuted in the state of
New York it'd be sort of weird to argue
that he couldn't be prosecuted in the
state of New York if he just shot
somebody on the street and the decision
from judge Victor Marrero a federal
district court Manhattan was the first
significant ruling in a case that could
require Trump to hand over his tax
returns and ultimately test the limits
of presidential power the judge
dismissed a lawsuit that had been filed
by Trump he was seeking to block a
subpoena for eight years of his personal
and corporate tax returns now listen is
this a fishing expedition yes it is a
fishing expedition there is no question
it is a fishing expedition the Attorney
General of the state of New York
openly made clear the day that she was
elected that she had the Trump
Organization and President Trump in her
sights which is a horrible prosecutorial
behavior you are supposed to prosecute
crime you are not supposed to prosecute
people you identified the crime you
investigate the crime and then you
prosecute the crime you don't say you
know who I don't like that trumpian
fellow it's so funny all the same people
who are saying that it is selective and
malicious for president Trump to ask the
Ukrainians to look into Joe Biden
despite widespread allegations at least
allegations whether they're verified or
not of corruption by Joe Biden and
hunter Biden his son in Ukraine the same
people are saying a lot the targeted
prosecution they are totally fine with a
targeted prosecution when the target of
the prosecution happens to have a name
rhyming with Donald Trump the judge
dismissed that lawsuit the Manhattan
district attorney demanded the records
in late August as part of an
investigation into hush money payments
made in the run-up to the 2016
presidential elections now that of
course has been the culmination of a
year's long effort to get President
Trump's tax returns for the moment his
tax returns remain protected his lawyers
quickly appealed to the Second Circuit
Court of Appeals in Manhattan they
agreed to temporarily to delay
enforcement of the subpoena while
considering arguments in the case judge
Marrero systematically dismantled the
president's arguments that investigating
a sitting president was unconstitutional
according to the New York Times the
judge said mr. Trump's lawyers were in
essence arguing that the president along
with his family associates in companies
were above the law he says this Court
finds aspects of such a doctrine
repugnant to the nation's governmental
structure and constitutional values this
of course would be a Bill Clinton
appointed judge the dispute pits the
Manhattan district attorney Cyrus Vance
against the president and his DOJ and
whosever has raised a host of issues
that have not been tested in the courts
the Constitution does not actually say
whether presidents can be charged with a
crime while in office the Supreme Court
has not in fact ruled on the issue so
this is certainly not going to be the
last word in the case look III think
President Trump should have revealed his
tax returns way back during the 2016
campaign I have no real rationale as to
why he didn't do that with that said is
the insane focus on Trump's tax returns
something that behooves prosecutorial
authorities probably not probably not
meanwhile and other impeachment news I
just have to point out the irony of
Hillary Clinton so Hillary Clinton who
is still wandering the woods of upstate
New York
sadly pretending that she is the
president of the United States like Miss
Havisham walking around in her old
wedding dress hey Hillary
Clinton she was on the TVs at yesterday
and she suggested that calling on
foreign adversaries for assistance in
campaigns goes to the heart of our
sovereignty it threatens our sovereignty
here is the illustrious non president
Hillary Clinton when you have a
president calling on foreign adversaries
for assistance in his political
campaigns which he did in 2016 and which
he is doing again that goes right to the
heart of our sovereignty as a nation to
our national security in a way that is
almost unimaginable I cannot imagine any
other president ever even thinking about
this could you imagine a president say
appealing to Chinese donors in the 1996
election and declassifying a bunch of
nuclear secrets at the same time because
you were married to that one could you
imagine a presidential candidate maybe
coordinating with the Ukrainian embassy
to dig up dirt on the opponent campaign
could you maybe imagine like a
presidential candidate coordinating with
foreign resources including a former
British spy who is apparently being fed
Intel from Russian governmental sources
about their political opponents and then
you know funneling that to your old
administration and your buddies and the
DOJ and the FBI could you imagine
anything like that I seem to be able to
imagine something like that cuz it
happened you know the the gaslighting of
this is what makes it so difficult as I
said yesterday as I talked about
yesterday when it comes to impeachment
one of the standards for impeachment is
that it has to be clearly above and
beyond other things that were not
impeached before and the fact the
Democrats seem to want to set a new
standard that only applies to people who
are not Democrats is pretty astonishing
by the way when it comes to impeachment
just to point out some of the media
coverage brian Stelter over at CNN he
has a reliable sources newsletter and he
points out the country's leading news
outlets are laying the groundwork for
long term coverage of the impeachment
inquiry and all the potential fallout it
is amazing how the media have resonated
to any anti Trump narrative they can
find whether you are talking about Dean
Baquet of the New York Times openly
acknowledging that the Trump Russia
thing was the focus of their last couple
of years and then stating and they were
gonna move into covering Trump racism
and now they're just moving straight on
to impeachment now you have brian
Stelter pointing out
that all of these newspapers and all
these organizations are hiring up and
staffing up on the impeachment stuff so
basically as soon as the Democrats throw
out a narrative it is time staff up on
the reporting side to do all of their
Apple research for them one of the
convenient things about being a
democratic opposition researcher is you
never actually have to work you can just
read the front page of the New York
Times which will dig up whether Mitt
Romney cut a gay kids hair back in 1952
it's really really exciting stuff it
will get to more of the new CNN higher
cNN has hired some new people and it
goes to show you exactly where CNN the
most trusted name in news is coming from
we'll get to that in just one moment
first let's talk about gun ownership so
as you know I'm a big fan of gun
ownership this is not only because I've
had personal safety issues it is also
because you should have you should
exercise your Second Amendment rights
your second Amendment rights I will
protect your First Amendment rights and
all of your other rights that are
guaranteed by the Bill of Rights every
year in America guns are used apparently
over two million times in self-defense
according to certain studies the average
self-defense legal case cost between
fifty and seventy thousand dollars for
the victim which can be shocking
especially when you consider that these
Americans were just defending themselves
and their loved ones like you or I would
know you think okay somebody comes in my
house and I shoot them that's the end of
the story in many cases not that's why
I'm excited to introduce our new
partnership with the u.s. concealed
carry Association the u.s. CCA was
founded in 2003 in response to the
growing threats to Americans rights
freedom and ability to defend themselves
they provide industry-leading
self-defense education training and
legal protection to over 300,000 members
in they are the fastest-growing
community of responsibly armed Americans
in the country plus they have fantastic
giveaways like for example this month
they are giving away $1000 to 19 lucky
winners for free you can buy a cig the
Glock and AR just takes to win - 87 - 2
- and claim your free entries there's no
catch the US CCA just believes in
helping protect responsible Americans
and gun ownership if you are responsible
American you should learn to use a gun
you should know how to use a gun and you
should get a gun and now you have the
opportunity to win one by texting 1 - 87
- 2 - to find out more and claim your
entries that is win WI n - 87 - 2 - ok
we're gonna get two more on impeachment
good Corddry know i 3 in just one second
first you have to go over to daily wire
comm and subscribe so right now let me
just tell you I could use a refreshing
swig from this the left
Cheers hot or cold hump ler if sadly
were not empty of leftist years why well
because the fact is that we've been on
break for a little while over the
weekend I've been flying in all of that
but don't worry soon it will replenish
you can have your own leftist yours
tumblr for 99 dollars a year and this
will be a magical experience for you it
will make sure that if the room is too
warm let's say and you are desperately
in need of a liquid you replenish
yourself that you can make this happen
for yourself go check it out over at
daily we're calm right now $99 zero gets
to the annual subscription you know the
pitch go do it we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so CNN has hired four new
contributors according to brian Stelter
very exciting stuff whoo
well Geoffrey angle a CNN presidential
historian and the co-author of
impeachment in American history I can't
imagine why they hired him Michael
Gerhart a CNN legal analyst and the
author of several books including in the
federal impeachment process a
constitutional and historical analysis
and a regular on CNN during the Clinton
impeachment Ross Garber a CNN legal
analyst who represents four governors
facing impeachment proceedings and
Washington Post's Shane Harris now CNN
at national security analyst who's been
part of the post team breaking big
stories about the whistleblower
complaint everybody else is staffing up
on the impeachment stuff as well so just
very very exciting stuff now then the
media are pointing out that very few
Republicans are appearing on television
to mount a defense of President Trump
part of that is because why would you so
you can get beat up like Ron Johnson was
by Chuck Todd like why exactly would you
sign up for that it's amazing to me to
watch how members of the media like we
can't book a Republican to talk about
this stuff also Republicans are the
worst and they're terrible horrible
people yes maybe it's because you
believe the latter that you can't get
the former that would be it but in other
breaking impeachment related news the
house is now allegedly subpoenaed White
House Budget Office and pentagon
documents now whether those are formal
subpoenas is unclear
so as Andy McCarthy has pointed out in
the last couple of weeks the fact is
that Democrats have been basically
issuing requests to executive branch
agencies for documents and then not
issuing formal subpoenas a formal
subpoena actually carries with it the
threat of contempt a non formal subpoena
does not carry that it's basically just
them pretending that they've subpoenaed
something and then they can complain
that it's being obstructed
even though usually use of peanut
document and then there's a negotiation
that takes place over what exactly the
documents are that are to be turned over
so the house has now expanded its
sprawling impeachment inquiry they've
issued subpoenas to the Defense
Department and OMB for documents that
could solve lingering mysteries about
whether Trump's decisions withhold
security aid for Ukraine was tied to his
efforts to pressure the government there
to investigate his political rivals now
in all likelihood by the way those
documents are likely to show that the
military aid was in fact
- corruption concerns do you really
think I mean if they fight by the way if
they come with a smoking gun here they
come with a smoking gun I just have my
serious doubts that the that the Trump
administration was sending notes to the
Defense Department saying gonna get G
Biden at the aid like III really don't
think that sign Donald J Trump like I
don't think that's where this is going
to senior American diplomats caught up
in the scandal are scheduled to speak to
investigators before the week is through
a third who is scheduled to be deposed
on Monday didn't show up but will show
up later lawmakers appeared to be in the
final stages of arranging a highly
secure interview with the anonymous CIA
whistleblower now again I don't know why
we're gonna pretend that this big that
the CA whistleblower has any new
information what was in the complaint is
now public and we know all of it and we
have the transcript of the phone call so
what is this person going to add the
answer is presumably nothing but this
person will also probably demonstrate
that they are a partisan Democrat
because in fact it appears they're
probably a partisan Democrat now does
that actually undermine the validity of
the complaint not really I mean we'll
have to find out what the facts actually
have to say about all of this I'm
president Trump said people understand
it's a fraud it's a scam it's a
witch-hunt all we do is keep fighting
for the American people because that's
all I do and then he calls his own
actions very terrific which is President
Trump I wish had been sometimes a
Broadway producer because he just his
raves for his own shows would have just
been spectacular senator rob portman
republican of ohio chastised President
Trump he said the president should not
have raised the Biden issue on that call
period it's not appropriate for a
president to engage a foreign government
in an investigation of a political
opponent now I tend to agree with that
although Rudy Giuliani's general point
which is okay well what if that general
political opponent happens to have
committed a crime right that's a real
question the problem is that there may
in fact be a disconnect between what
Giuliani thought was happening in
Ukraine and what Trump lets happen
thought was happening in Ukraine and
what was actually happening in Ukraine
so Trump very well could have thought
that there was corruption it's almost a
mirror image of the Mobil report so on
the one hand what you see in Muller
report land is a dual narrative the
narrative of the left is that there is a
good reason for opening the model report
that there are serious suspicions about
Trump and Russia and just because the
goods were not fully delivered
does not mean that there was not
accuracy to the the suspicions in the
first place on the right people say no
no this thing was launched in bad faith
who was obviously meant to go after
Trump it was broadened out from man
afford to include President Trump the
whole thing was a gotcha
from the beginning well now we are
seeing the exact same logic applied in
Reverse with regard to Ukraine and Biden
some people on the right including the
president are saying listen I was
interested in Ukrainian corruption and
Joe Biden's name was obviously part of
the story here Glenn Beck actually did
an entire show about the timeline in
Ukraine and it is kind of suspicious I
mean when Biden got involved versus when
his son was was made the a member of the
chair a member of the board of burries
ma I mean that that timeline does look
suspicious so Republicans are like well
this thing was launched in good faith
and even if it comes up with nothing
that doesn't mean it was launched in bad
faith Democrats are saying no no it was
totally launched in bad faith because
Joe Biden is president Trump's political
rival and the answer is we'll have to
wait and see in both cases right we're
still awaiting the Inspector General
report on the origins of the Trump
Russia probe and we're gonna have to see
whether the Biden thing was caught up in
a generalized corruption investigation
by the administration or whether it was
just a political attempt to target Biden
that was sort of papered over with the
facade of concern about corruption the
new subpoenas were issued by the
Democrat controlled House Intelligence
Committee and they follow similar
demands for documents from the State
Department and the White House made in
recent days but those were not actually
subpoenas that's as I was pointing out
subpoenas come with legal consequences
these do not they gave the agencies
until October 15th to hand over notes
memos and communications and
communications related to the age of
liberation over its delivery within the
government and possible conversations
with Ukrainian officials about it
Democrats leading the impeachment
inquiry suspect that obviously military
aid was withheld in order to pressure
Joe Biden the Defense Department had
been anticipating the subpoena last week
the Pentagon's general counsel directed
all department heads to collect and turn
in all documents and material related to
military aid to Ukraine so once again
this doesn't look like an active
obstruction one one of the funny things
about this particular impeachment
inquiry is that it's actually a lot
easier to prove a cover-up than it is to
prove a crime
I take Watergate for example there still
is not solid evidence that President
Nixon explicitly ordered an
to go break into the Watergate Hotel
there is explicit evidence that he
ordered to cover up it's easier to prove
the cover-up because there are a lot
more people involved in the cover-up
then the crime usually gonna use a
go-between for the crime anyway okay
well in this particular case if there's
no cover-up how do you prove the crime
particularly because you have to show
intent it's not just enough to show the
president Trump set up a quid pro quo
with regard to corruption because Joe
Biden did that now you actually have to
show that his intent was to get Biden
and not to target corruption at all Rudy
Giuliani meanwhile says that he is
thinking of suing Adam chef he said he's
working with outside lawyers to prepare
lawsuits against Schiff as well as
representative a shooter to leave of
Michigan he said that those legal plans
were made over the weekend in a series
of calls with Yahoo News amid cable news
appearances in which he aggressively
defended President Trump apparently
Giuliani has dismissed at least one
critic of such a lawsuit as a nitwit
arguing there are no constitutional
constraints on bringing such litigation
against sitting members of Congress he
says that Schiff is seeking to inhibit
me in my ability to defend Trump by
criticizing him he says that they are
attempting to deprive him of civil
rights and engaging the conspiracy to
remove the president at all costs I'm
not sure that suable even if it is
troubling and even if you agree with the
characterization not everything that is
troubling is suable okay meanwhile in
the 2020 race Joe Biden is all but dead
Elizabeth Warren has now taken a narrow
lead over Joe Biden in the race for the
Democratic presidential nomination
according to a new October IBD investor
business daily TI PP poll both
candidates continued to lead in
head-to-head matchups against Trump
although Biden has more comfortable lead
Warren is only leading very narrowly
according to this polling data the poll
shows Warren at 27 and Biden at 26 but
he has been sliding quickly he is now
second in the vast majority of the new
polls Bernie Sanders has completely
fallen out of the races all the way down
at 10 percent the heart attack obviously
is not going to help his support will
probably kick over to Elizabeth Warren
Joe Biden is is lagging in fundraising
as well in third quarter Biden raised
only 15 point 2 million dollars while
Warren raised at 25 as did Bernie
Sanders the October IB DTI PP poll found
more an edging Trump by just two points
48 to 46 that was even slimmer the
her lead in September so well Elizabeth
Warren will be a competitive nominee it
is certainly no foregone conclusion that
she will be President Trump the fact is
president Trump is an expert at dragging
people through the mud it is his thing
he is great at it and Elizabeth Warren
is ripe for the picking
not only on the pocahontas kind of stuff
but also because she's kind of dishonest
about her own policies I mean I've
talked about this on the show Elizabeth
Warren used to be an interesting human
and now she is a full-scale Bernie ight
progressive who refuses to answer
straight questions about whether she's
gonna raise your taxes Trump should have
a lot of material to work with he really
should so that a lot of politics is
about expectation versus reality the
expectation for President Trump and the
reality of President Trump are identical
nobody has expectations that have not
been met if you believe that President
Trump is a godsend then your
expectations meet your reality and if
you believe that President Trump is the
worst president ever your expectations
meet your reality and if you're
somewhere in the middle your
expectations meet your reality because
Trump can fulfill all those conditions
for you there is nothing hidden about
the man everything is out on the surface
however if Elizabeth Warren is perceived
as an anti-corruption fighter if she is
pure as the driven snow if the hem of
her skirt has never been muddied
President Trump is a mud monster he
embraces other candidates and they walk
away covered in mud that is what
President Trump does best so if
Elizabeth Warren is riding at 48 percent
right now and Trump is riding at 46
percent in that poll Elizabeth Warren
might actually be in some trouble
because again she has not had one iota
of negative press attention since that
ridiculous DNA test that she took at the
beginning of this year since then it has
been nothing but glowing reports written
by her sycophants in the media who are
carrying around drool cups for her I
mean they literally drooling into cups
over at Elizabeth Warren it's insane
and so Joe Biden he's been trashed
this lends credence to all the folks who
have been claiming that President Trump
in the Ukraine stuff it's all about
taking down Joe Biden's that he can run
against Elizabeth Warren again I think
that accident and stupidity is much more
a motivating force in human affairs than
his detailed planning but I guess if you
want to make the case like some folks do
that Trump for tea chests this thing out
and that he was talking with Ukraine
because he knew that Ukraine was
eventually going to spill its beans
and then eventually all this was gonna
come out and it would sink Joe Biden I
guess he can make that case although the
reality is of course the Joe Biden was
sliding in the polls at least a month
and a half two months ago so the Ukraine
thing is just the final nail in his
political coffin this new poll by the
way shows that Warren has now displaced
Sanders as the candidate of the far left
she now has the support of 38% of
self-described liberals among Democrats
Biden is at 14% among white voters
Warren is ahead of Biden 33 to 20 by
Dhin still ahead 44 to 16 among black
and Hispanic voters but that could
obviously change over time among
Democratic investors 31% back Elizabeth
Warren versus 23% for Joe Biden which
just goes to show you that a lot of
Democrats who invest their money
apparently care about their money a lot
less than they care about politics so I
guess good for them I guess they're
putting their money where their mouth is
they're also putting your money where
their mouth is which is far less
exciting now one wrinkle that may throw
a a serious wrinkle into the next
election cycle is this news story that
Justice Clarence Thomas is absent due to
illness from the Supreme Court obviously
the justices of the Supreme Court are
getting up there in terms of age there
are some of them that are that are
really getting up there Ruth Bader
Ginsburg of course is 86 years old if
God forbid something were to happen to
Ruth Bader Ginsburg then presumably I
mean it would just throw a wrench like a
massive wrench into the 2020 election
campaign if Justice Scalia had not died
in 2016 there's a good shot Trump
doesn't win that election Clarence
Thomas is only 71 years old but he is
sick to start the term Stephen Breyer is
81 years old which everybody is ignoring
right he who's been on the court since
1994 everybody else is why younger so
those would those would be the three to
keep your eye on in terms of health
issues maybe well though 71 is still
pretty young right it's younger than
President Trump Ruth Bader Ginsburg in
86 and Stephen priority-one both liberal
justices if something were to happen to
either one of them that would change the
dynamics in the race extraordinarily
extraordinarily radically because
everybody is focused in on the Supreme
Court and its future constituency so
we'll get to more of that a little bit
tomorrow and maybe a little bit later on
today's show on the radio show we'll get
into the Supreme Court cases that are
coming up okay time for the thing I like
and then time for some things that I
hate so things that I like
today so today is Yom Kippur tonight
marks a Yom Kippur actually my first
time doing Yom Kippur in Israel I've
heard that it's amazing like the entire
country it shuts down to Colton's great
horror and shock because Colton will not
be able it's it's like Christmas Day in
the United States where he can't
actually go out to a right in just buy
anything everything shut down except
that no cars run everybody is in
synagogue so congratulations Colton you
came on the on your day my friend but
Yom Kippur is an amazing holiday it's a
wonderful opportunity to really sort of
reconsider Yom Kippur is a day where
everything basically shuts down
throughout Israel there are no cars
there
there's no electronics effectively
speaking it is the day of atonement it
is the day when everybody is supposed to
pour out their sins before God and
they're supposed to engage in teshuva -
fela and sadaqa that would be repentance
and prayer and charity giving and and
it's frankly it's a pretty amazing thing
like spiritually speaking it's a pretty
amazing thing the opportunity the
kindness of if you're believer in God
the kindness of a God who will forgive
your sins is an incredible thing I think
people get the wrong impression of
Judaism and forgiveness we're big on
this for a long time before the other
major world religions we're out there on
it so Yom Kippur it's pretty special day
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
okay so stupid piece of the day Davian
Leonhardt said the rich really do pay
lower taxes than you yeah dude
no no they do not that is called stupid
so he says that this is because they are
paying lower effective tax rates than
other groups because they're paying
lower rates in terms of because they
have capital gains and many other groups
do not have capital gains okay yes and
then in terms of the income tax they're
paying exorbitant ly more than anybody
else I love that David Linares is the
overall tax rate on the richest 400
households last year was only 23% yes
because the richest 400 households are
basically sitting on earned interest and
they're sitting on investments
then there are a lot of people intent
the 1% which is a lot bigger than 400
household or paying insane insane income
tax effective income tax rates in some
states like California if you combine
the federal income tax rate and the
effective income tax rate in the state
of California and then you include
things like sales tax and property tax
people are paying over 50% of what they
make to the federal and state government
that's not happening at the lower end of
the tax bracket but david Leonhardt has
I mean talk about lying with statistics
the overall tax rate on the richest 400
households last year was only 23%
meaning that their combined tax payments
equaled less than one quarter of their
total income this overall rate was 70%
in 1950 and 47% to 1980
yes and people paid the same effective
at tax rate because they engaged in what
we call tax avoidance he said for
middle-class and poor families the
picture is different federal income
taxes have declined modestly for these
families over the years but they haven't
benefited much of it all from the
decline in corporate tax or estate tax
yes because if you're poor you don't
have that much to hand on in a state tax
and you also don't own a corporation so
you also don't make money in corporate
tax like yes that's true but you are
probably engaged by a corporation and
probably the people who hired you who
already pay tax by the way on the money
that they want to hand on to their kids
may like they're the ones who are paying
you the estate tax by the way is utterly
immoral it's immoral on every level I
earn money over the course of my life
and I pay taxes all the way along every
dollar I own I paid taxes on one of the
goals of me earning money is to pass it
on to my kids the government
grave-robbing me by coming in and
grabbing my money after I am dead
because they believe that they have a
right to my money a second time over its
complete abject moral crap hey but this
kind of stuff is absolute nonsense
here's the actual statistic the top 20
percent of Americans as of 2018 pay 87
percent of all income tax in the country
households with 150 thousand dollars or
more an income make up about 52 percent
of total income nationally but pay 87
percent of the total income tax so stop
lying about the progressiveness of the
American income tax it's just a lie it's
just a bunch of nonsense ok we'll be
back here later today with a couple of
additional hours otherwise we'll see you
after Yom Kippur after the atonement is
done I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you